HAOHSIANG LIAO: Here
at MIT, we usually
require students to prepare
for a one hour class
for about an hour and a half.
So that's the time
that we expect students
to give to this course,
because it's a 12 unit course,
so that's a pretty
reasonable time expected.
And students, they
can usually do it.
But how can students, then,
make the best out of those 90
minutes is a totally
different field,
that so far we don't have
enough resources to know
what do they exactly do
during these 90 minutes.
Because too often,
students would
say that I followed every
procedure that you recommended,
but I feel the result is
not that satisfactory.
What am I supposed to do more?
And in this case, we usually
provide individualizations.
So we have the students come
into our office and tell them,
show me how you prepare
for class, and observe.
So I give you 10 minutes.
So you do your preparations
here in my office,
and I observe, and based
on those 10 to 15 minutes
students, I give
you my feedback.
What I observe is A, you spend
too much on this and this,
and you are too silent.
You cannot be too silent
when you prepare for classes,
because in class it's
about production.
Productions are very
loud, so this kind
of loudness or the loud
part should reflected
from your preparation.
And from the 10
minutes or 15 minutes,
you're silent for 12 minutes,
which is not the case in class.
Whenever student is say well, I
do this, this, this, and this,
you really don't know how much
you can trust them in that way.
So the best way to check is
to have them here and show you
how they prepare for the class.